(APPLAUSE)
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH CRAIGSLIST,
AND THE REASON IS BECAUSE
YOU POSTED THIS AD
FOR THE WANGCASTER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> NO!
>> Chris: THE BEST WAY TO PLAY
A D-FLAT.
(SLIGHT LAUGHTER)
>> NO!
>> Chris: I KNOW, I KNOW.
THEY'RE NOT ALL GOLD.
YEP, THAT'S A DICK-SHAPED
GUITAR, GUYS.
THE BIGGEST DICK IN THE ROOM
IS NOW NO LONGER THE GUY
PLAYING "STAIRWAY TO HEAVEN"
IN THE GUITAR CENTER.
IN HONOR OF THIS BRAVE NEW
INVENTION, TONIGHT'S HASHTAG
IS #SCHLONGSONGS.
(LAUGHTER)
SOMETIMES I HAVE TO EXPLAIN
TO MY MOM WHAT IT IS I GET PAID
TO DO.
SO EXAMPLES OF #SCHLONGSONGS
WOULD BE "GLORY HOLE DAYS,"
"TAINT NOTHING LIKE THE REAL
THING," "HELL'S BALLS."
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK, AND GO.
YES, NEAL.
>> PURPLE VEIN.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: OH!
BY PRINCE ALBERT.
POINTS.
MICHELLE.
>> (BLEEP) TO MY WINDOW.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
DAN.
>> MAMA SAID SUCK YOU OUT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEAL BRENNAN.
>> THEME FROM SHAFT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
MICHELLE.
>> CAN'T TOUCH PISS.
>> Chris: EW, POINTS.
NEAL.
>> TANGLED UP IN PUBES.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
>> SO GROSS.
>> Chris: DAN.
>> WRECKING BALLS IN MY MOUTH.
>> Chris: YOU COULD HAVE STOPPED
AT "WRECKING BALLS" BUT I WILL
GIVE YOU POINTS ANYWAY
FOR GOING THE EXTRA MILE.
MICHELLE.
>> STAR SPANGLED BONER.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: FOR THE NOD TO THE